public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur
public sénat l'épreuve de vérité
ce soir c'est hervé morin bonjour
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
président de la région normandie avec
nos partenaires radio classique les
échos charlotte gauthier bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous et la fp représenté
aujourd'hui par paul aubry ya trois
parties dans cette émission avec trois
questions hervé morin est tout d'abord
sur la stratégie du gouvernement en
matière de réformes
première question est-ce que le
gouvernement va trop loin et trop vite
dans ses réformes
deuxième partie deuxième question c'est
là on peut y aller non non non non je
vous énumérez voir les trois questions
deuxième partie deuxième question sur
les relations entre macro et les élus
locaux
pourquoi tant d'incompréhensions et puis
troisième partie de cette émission nous
demanderons le centre combien de
divisions alors que jean-christophe
lagarde a été élu samedi président de
l'udps et y que vous vous pilotez les
centristes sans oublier la formation de
jean arthuis ou encore le modem donc
tout de suite première partie de
l'émission avec cette question le
gouvernement va-t-il trouver en matière
de réformes première partie et palau
briacé
[Musique]
fall braya première question bonsoir est
mort en bon soir alors est ce que ce
gouvernement trop vite en matière de
réformes
est ce que ces réformes sont nuisibles
visible ou devrait-il ralentir la
cadence pour moi la question se pose pas
en ces termes c'est est ce qu'on est
dans le cosmétique ou on est dans le
fond de la réforme c'est ça le débat je
trouve honnêtement que le gouvernement
est plutôt mou du genou depuis plusieurs
semaines je vois tous ces articles à
paraître sur le fait que le gouvernement
réforme à fond ma chute à pardon de le
dire mais la réforme de l'assurance
chômage le gouvernement a accepté
globalement la signature des partenaires
sociaux c'est à dire une situation dans
laquelle on ne gère pas et on ne règle
pas notamment la question d'un certain
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi dont on
voit bien que avec la reprise de la
croissance avec des secteurs d'activités
entiers qui recherchent de la main
d'oeuvre et des qualifications une
partie de nos compatriotes joue pour
l'emploi comme une agence d'intérim pour
rechercher les droits et donc ne joue
pas pleinement le fait d'aller à la
recherche de lampard en fait en vérité
il ya trois couches dans une migraine
important c'est à dire et on y reviendra
mais je pense que pour bien comprendre
il ya ceux qui sont très éloignées de
l'emploi
je pense que le grand plan
d'investissement sur les compétences du
gouvernement je l'espère aidera à ce que
ses compatriotes puissent revenir vers
l'emploi ya ce qu'on appelle le chômage
frictionnel il ya une partie de nos
compatriotes qui très clairement nous le
vois bien sans des régions puisque nous
assurons la formation des demandeurs
d'emploi nous avons aujourd'hui de plus
en plus de mal à remplir nos formations
c5 sujet moi quand j'ouvre une formation
une formation sur deux néo punk est
plein à moins de 50% exemple la réforme
sur l'apprentissage je pense que ce sera
un échec absolument totale clairement je
le crois troisièmement je prends sur la
réforme de l'apprentissage le miz
l'éducation nationale nous avait dit
vous serez compétents et vous aurez
l'autorité pour assurer l'orientation
j'ai le sentiment que sur ce sujet
gouvernement hésite beaucoup troisième
réforme dont on verra contenu la réforme
de la formation professionnelle
là aussi réforme systémique absolument
majeur est centrale dans un pays qui
retrouve la croissance est là aussi et
besoins de qualification de compétences
et où honnêtement pour l'instant le
grand soir de la réforme c'est à dire
enfin pilotage unique avec une vraie
politique de l'emploi coordonnées piloté
par les régions parce qu'il faut des
acteurs je sois proche du terrain je
suis pas convaincu qu'on a franchement
non plus vers une simplification et une
meilleure organisation d'un secteur dont
tout le monde s'accorde à reconnaître
que ce le pilotage absolument complexe
et source d'inefficacité
on entend que sur le fond vous dites que
ces cosmétiques mais sur le rythme
beaucoup de d2b là on verrait sur le
ferroviaire par les 8 et 10
c'est du de la durée forme bombing même
macron enchaîne bing ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il ne fait qu'enchaîner
et tous les deux jours il annonce une
réforme tous les deux jours
il ya une nouvelle un nouveau texte en
commission eux mêmes se disent noyer du
coup ils sont à rabâcher les mêmes
arguments ils n'ont pas le temps de
travailler sur le fond est ce que ça
pour vous c'est un problème je pense
qu'il faut d'ailleurs ayant été membre
de ce gouvernement quand j'entends ça on
avait passé de formule 1 en 2007 2008
j'ai le sentiment en tant que nicolas
sarkozy évoquait et voter redisant je
fais des réformes tous azimuts pour
conclure personne ne puisse quand car on
ne puisse pas s'appuyer sur une réforme
pour qu'elle devienne le symbole d'une
révolte sociale pour faire comme d'un
mouvement social profond donc quand
j'entends ça j'ai le sentiment de me
retrouver en 2007
en vérité ce dont ont besoin nos
compatriotes et ce dont a besoin la
france ce sont des transformations
systémiques et structurels il y en a eu
parce qu'en matière de fiscalité de
politique de l'offre il ya des choses
très bien qu'ils ont été menées et je ne
le conteste pas je trouve que depuis
quelques semaines on a plus parfois de
la non ce que du contenu alors selon le
sondage réalisé chaque semaine avec
notre partenaire opinionway et bien les
personnes interrogées sont plutôt
satisfaites de ce rythme des réformes
engagées à 41% à 1 trouve que ça va au
bon rythme même pour certaines personnes
à 24% des personnes interrogées n'a même
pas assez vite
mais le bon rythme ça veut rien dire un
passé ce qui est dans quoi on peut
toujours se raconter ce qu'on veut le
bon rythme à écouter si c'était 41-24 ça
fait soixante cinq un gros noyau c'est
ça moi j'observe que le présent un
public n'est pas ce niveau là de de
popularité comment expliquer justement
cette décorrélation entre ce résultat de
son âge depuis la popularité de
l'exécutif qui qui baise qui s'érode
depuis quelques semaines un bas il ya
des causes conjoncturelles dont on peut
estimer qu'elles vont s'effacer avec le
temps les 80 km heure sur les routes
[Musique]
dray a senti mans profonde injustice une
partie de nos compatriotes sont les
retraités
et puis ensuite il ya très clairement
des causes plus structurelle est plus
fondamental c'est le décrochage des
classes populaires qui ne se
reconnaissent plus dans la politique du
gouvernement il ya le monde rural qui a
le sentiment que il faut être dans la
mondialisation heureuse pour être servi
donc tous ces éléments-là créer ce
sentiment de satisfaction
justement à ce sujet vous parlez des
retraités du pouvoir d'achat des ehpad
de la sncf à venir avec la greffe pearl
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils pourraient
y avoir une convergence des fronts de
convergence des luttes
est ce que le gouvernement doit le
craindre il n'y a pas de tente de le
vrai combat du moca le réforme qui est
très très totémique qui est celle de la
sncf
j'espère qu'on l'amènera vraiment
je pense que le climat est absolument
différentes 1995 dans la mesure où la
qualité du service et terriblement
dégradée suffit d'être normand pour le
comprendre mais jamais un train à
l'heure les trains qui sont pas propres
n'y a pas d'eau dans les trains enfin
c'est les situations tous les jours que
vivent nos compatriotes avec le
ferroviaire il constate que c'est de
plus en plus cher et que la qualité du
service s'est réduite bien laisser le
ciel fut d'ailleurs n'y ait pas n'est
pas la seule responsable c'est d'abord
l'état qui est responsable pour la
plupart du temps pourquoi parce qu'on a
laissé se dégrader un réseau ferroviaire
conte sur lequel on n'a pas investi à
ces vous prenez la gare saint lazare
il n'y a pas eu de travaux je parle sur
les voies majeures depuis 1937 ça vous
donne une idée donc
donc on voit bien qu'on a
une un point de fixation qui je le crois
dans l'état actuel des choses ne
devraient pas être soutenus par nos
compatriotes comme on l'avait vécu à 95
ne faut pas oublier 95
au début les français étaient avec le
gouvernement moi je m'en souviens très
bien
j'étais collaborateur françois léotard à
l'époque je m'en souviens et donc et et
quelques semaines après les choses
s'étaient fixé je crois pas qu'on soit
sûr ce sur ce même j'apprends de
multiplier les fronts à ce que le
gouvernement ne prend pas un risque il
n'y a pas tant de fronts ça il ya la
sncf ya en effet et retraités vous mais
on n'imagine pas les retraités tout d'un
coup devenir un facteur de de crise
sociale majeure
après il ya en effet des populations des
métiers qui vont mal aux éleveurs une
partie de l'agriculture etc
mais je ne ressens pas je pense que nos
compatriotes sont encore dans la tente
dans l'observation
ils ont envie que ça marche moi aussi
j'ai envie ça marche je premier à
espérer que ça marche et je
j'applaudirais dès demain ainsi en effet
nous faisons les réformes que le pays
attend et le moins ouais mon inquiétude
c'est plus que on ne fasse les choses
vraiment qu'à moitié
sinon moins qu'à moitié et le
gouvernement compte tenir bon fait en
tout cas ce qu'a dit hier bruno le maire
sur france inter on va l'écouter
alain juppé en 95 avait essayé de tenir
très longtemps et on voit comment ça
s'est terminé est ce que vous vous êtes
sur l'optique quelle que soit la grève
et quelle que soit la durée de la grève
on tiendra beau nous tiendrons oui nous
tiendrons le maire très affirmatif donc
un gouvernement dise aux débuts de la
réforme s'il ne disait pas savoir s'ils
souffraient il faudrait s'inquiéter
le cheminot ou prévoit des grèves des
grèves perlées
ça vous inquiète on a encore retombée
dans ce vocable prise d'otages des
usagers etc fêtera comment vous comment
vous percevez ces annonces de grève
voilà c'est ça va être une source
d'inquiétude mais absolument gigantesque
voit bien
5 la stratégie de la sn2 des cheminots
c'est un système de grève perlée
probablement parce que aujourd'hui la
cgt n'est peut-être pas situation n'est
probablement pas en situation de pouvoir
tenir une grève dure complète et totale
sur le long terme si j'en crois ce que
me disent qu'on me dit donc à partir de
là la grève perlée devient la solution
elle est source de voilà deux questions
qu'est ce qu'on recherche à travers ça
c'est le fait de se donner du temps pour
qu'il y est en quelque sorte une
sédimentation d'un mouvement de
contestation qui deviennent le plus fort
possible vous paraît que 30 15 ça c'est
un peu passé comme ça en 81 95 du jour
au lendemain vous étiez trop jeune
vedette encore et encore et et et en 95
ça a été une grève dure et totale
complète à dire que tout d'un coup on a
vu des centaines de milliers de
compatriotes émerger qui tous les jours
prenait le métro prenait le train et qui
se retrouvaient sur le trottoir pour
aller bosser et donc c'était une grève
est absolument totale
mais bon en tant que président région
c'est quelque chose qui vous fait peur
veut dire vos administrés il vous en
parle c'est quelque chose que vous
verserez t je suis un démocrate
j'ai et j'ai voilà la république
elle a inscrit dans sa constitution
l'exercice du droit de grève quel que
soit le caractère exaspérante cela je
n'oublie pas que nous vivons dans un
état de droit et dans une démocratie et
on vous dit qu'il fallait vite sur la
forme de la sncf et recourir il donc je
suis favorable aux ordonnances est
favorable aux ordonnances comme
effectivement une majorité aussi des
personnes qu'on a interrogés toujours
dans notre sondage opinionway sur le
recours aux ordonnances 10 y sont
favorables à 59% donc près de 60% donc
ça pour vous c'est la bonne piste
oui je pense qu'il faut aller vite sans
hésiter à les juger on les connaît par
coeur il faut l'ouverture à la
concurrence pour faire en sorte que nous
ayons des coûts du ferroviaire moins
élevé on sait que dans tous les pays où
la concurrence était ouverte le train
baisse
on a des cours entre 30 et 50% plus
élevé que les allemands comportant une
compagnie nationale on a des coûts sur
l'ensemble des infrastructures et des
réseaux plus
et aussi on sait que si on fait appel à
la concurrence on pourra réduire le coût
des travaux
voilà on a besoin de ça on a besoin de
ça aille vite et on a besoin qu'en 2019
les régions puissent ouvrir à la
concurrence à centre de ligne j'ai pas
d'ouvrir les plus grandes lignes je me
vois pas ouvrir à la concurrence paris
caen cherbourg mais on a sur un centre
de voix la capacité de pouvoir bâtir des
modèles qui me semble-t-il sont
susceptibles d'intéresser des compagnies
privées
alors après la question de l'ouverture à
la concurrence elle dépendra beaucoup
des conditions si c'est pour couvrir des
mêmes règles
les acteurs privés qui viendront et est
clair que c'est une ouverture à la
concurrence en trompe l'oeil
d'où le fait que j'attends de voir
exactement le contenu de tout cela allez
on poursuit et dans les chantiers
ouverts par le gouvernement avec
notamment paul la réforme
constitutionnelle
c'est votre grande réforme du moment
aujourd'hui edouard philippe a présenté
ses conclusions à emmanuel macron alors
plusieurs points ce week end une
nouvelle boucliers notamment à droite et
la première la première de ces de cette
levée de boucliers c'est la baisse du
nombre de parlementaires qu'on voudrait
ramener à 400 députés contre 557
aujourd'hui qui est contre personne
alors vous pouvez jeu parlementaire j'ai
été député pendant la bataille
je ne savent pas mais j'ai été
administrateur de l'assemblée nationale
avant c'est-à-dire ces fonctionnaires
qui sont les des parlementaires
et qui rédige les rapports qui apporte
le conseil technique et juridique bien
j'ai connu donc le parlement 489 c'était
un parlement pourrait travailler plus
facilement quand vous avez des
commissions à 130 120 surprendre député
il pas trahir et elle en plus encore
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes dans un
système où comme vous avez des comme les
commissions sont publiques des
parlementaires
après son dans les espèces de
classification
mon député ou je ne sais quoi là tout
s'est tous et tous ces sites qui donc
était tout est donc les donc les donc
comme les notations sont en fonction du
nombre d'interventions donc ils sentent
obligés tue tout ça donc je le sais
d'intervenir pour montrer qu'il aurait
en effet moi je suis favorable pour
qu'il y ait des réunions de commissions
qu'ils soient les plus constructif
possible où on puisse vraiment faire la
loi et deuxièmement pardon maintenant
qu'il ya plus de cumul des mandats il ya
absolument pas de responsabilité pour
576 que nous compliquerait les épaules
et jusqu'à combien non mais ça c'est
bien moi j'ai toujours proposer 400 m a
été très bien il faut bien que nous
compatriotes comprennent que derrière ça
on n'est pas dans une casse où on peut
intervenir à tout moment
le débat parlementaire est extrêmement
codifié il ya un parlementaire par
groupe et donc vous avez des députés qui
ne sont même pas ne peuvent pas dans
l'hémicycle intervenir pour apporter une
contribution ou une solution en limiter
le droit d'amendement non c'était déjà
il a été limité suffisamment comme ça
mais on a 400 députés si on a moins de
sénateurs on s'en portera pas plus mal
non plus et donc ça c'est le premier
chant et sur la proportionnelle
alors on y arrive effectivement combien
déboursant 24 ans comme le préconise
voudrais vous examinez goody
à combien le grinch parce que propose
lexus ça m'est égal
mais ce que je sais c'est qu'il va alors
on est d'accord et donc ce que ce qu'il
faut c'est suffisamment de
parlementaires sinon ça n'a pas de sens
il faut que nos compatriotes comprennent
là aussi que si ces dix ou si c'est 15
si vous êtes un parti politique qui fait
15% aux 18% enfin peu importe vous allez
avoir combien de députés deux trois
quatre cinq
est ce qu'avec deux trois quatre ou cinq
parlementaires une formation politique
qui fait 15 ou 20 % est en capacité
d'avoir une expression politique
suffisant non donc n'est donc il faut
que derrière ça ya la capacité pour des
formations politiques qui ne gagne pas
de sièges au scrutin majoritaire d'avoir
un groupe parlementaire
parce qu'ici a pas de groupe
parlementaire ya pas d'expression
politique et si ya pas d'expression
politique
on a fait une proportionnelle pour rien
sauf pour permettre à quelques leader
d'un parti politique de rentrée au
parlement où la belle affaire
et donc c'est pas ça le sujet le sujet
c'est fair en sorte qu'il y ait des
familles politiques pour lesquelles je
n'ai aucun point aucun point commun
j'ai aucun point commun avec le front
national très bien il fonda chirac doit
être présent à l'assemblée nationale
c'est très simple donc 20% 25 points il
est là les vins un niveau alors après il
ya 125 pour dia la symbolique ya
recettes
ouais il ya la recette il n'y a pas
simplement le fait d'afficher sait
comment font les choses à 6,6 et voilà
alors répartie santé je vois que vous je
vois que vous avez tout ça en tête
mais moi je pense que cette
proportionnelle elle doit être
correctives si le chiffre est bas c'est
à dire qu'il ne doit pas s'adresser à
ceux qui auraient fait beaucoup plus que
si ça n'avait tech à la proportionnelle
il faut inventer en quelques sortes un
système à l'allemande ou il ya un
correctif entre deux scrutins
majoritaires tel qu'il a donné des
résultats et le scrutin proportionnel
s'il avait été complètement impliqué et
parce que c'est
c'est une question de démocratie si on
veut que le parlement c'est un lieu de
débat de référence
il faut que les grands mouvements
politiques du pays y soient représentés
alors il ya un troisième point c'est le
non cumul des mandats dans le temps des
élus et notamment des élus locaux
celui-là il fait bondir la ouate en
particulier la droite sénatoriale
et ben moi aussi vous aussi pourquoi
vous que vous vous estimez pas légitime
la demande de certains mais pour croiser
pourquoi voudriez vous qu un maire qui
fait son boulot me dise monsieur rentrez
chez vous en vertu de quoi les petites
communes ne sont pas concernés trois
mille cinq mois j'ai jugé pardon j'ai à
dire que je suis fier à bras j'étais
j'ai été maire pendant 20 ans ma commune
je pensais avoir transformé en
profondeur je faisais des scores
dithyrambiques qui à chaque élection
bien plus que ce que représentait ma
famille politique
en vertu de quoi on aura empêché les
habitants de la commune de continuer à
élire des délires leur mère s'il le
souhaitait je comprends pas cette
histoire là que pour le goûter ligne
rouge pour vour le parlement je suis
d'accord ok trois mandats c'est un petit
mot de la corse avant de finir cette
partie avec vous paul parce qu'elle est
grosse déception du corps tout à l'heure
en sortant du bureau de jacky moreau
j'ai pas vu la dépêche mais je vais
donner au gouvernement
l'introduction d'un alinéa à l'article
72 de la constitution spécifiquement
dédié à la corse où seraient notamment
reconnu dans cet alinéa insularité de la
corse et mais sans mentionner
l'autonomie c'est vers cela que le
gouvernement se dirigeraient dans sa
copie est ce que ça vous semble
suffisant l'introduction d'un alinéa
côté vous voyons ce que ça donne déjà si
la corse c'est déjà une revendication
qui est en quelque sorte acceptée
puisque ça faisait partie des
revendications de gilles simeoni de ses
deux compères ce que je veux simplement
qu'on entende c'est que il est logique
que la corse est un statut particulier
de par son insularité
de par sa culture de par ces
problématiques propres mais j'allais
dire ça ne devrait pas déranger le coup
là je ne suis pas d'accord avec toutes
les propositions il ya une pollution
lesquels j'ai pas d'accord mais très
clairement il faut jamais oublier d'où
vient la corse ce qu'est la corse ce
qu'est la culture de la corse ne pas
oublier que c'est unique a été achetée
qui a fait la guerre contre la france
pendant des décennies tout ça voilà
c'est peut-être de l'histoire lointaine
mais c'est une île qui est assez
problématique et ses spécificités et
l'élection de décembre dernier c'est pas
une élection simplement d'une majorité
et donc il faut que le gouvernement
entende et il devrait pas avoir de mal à
l'entendre dans la mesure où il a
accepté l'idée de la différenciation des
collectivités ça veut dire quoi que des
collectivités n'est pas les mêmes
compétences d'une région à l'autre
donc il est assez cohérent que la corse
puisse avoir en effet un statut
particulier
on passe à la seconde partie de cette
émission hervé morin sur les relations
entre macro et les élus locaux font
[Musique]
avec cette question charlatans oui alors
parmi les mesures qui fâchent maquereau
et le gouvernement et les élus locaux
c'est celle des 80 km heure celle là
elle provoque un tollé pas possible
c'est 80 km heure sur les routes
secondaires vous y êtes favorable vous
monsieur morin vous entendez l'argument
des 400 morts en moins par an est-ce
qu'on a enfin vraiment l'enquète
d'études tels que on l'a pas eue pendant
des semaines
je sais pas j'ai vu des bouts de j'ai vu
des boues d'études dans vos dans les
journaux diverses et variées j'ai jamais
compris pourquoi le gouvernement vous
l'avez pas donné immédiatement vous
l'avez réclamez-vous par exemple coûte
et je fais confiance aux parlementaires
pour leur demander
il ya un moment je finis par ne plus
être convaincu par les limitations de
vitesse successives voilà
par exemple on a beaucoup limité la
vitesse sur les autoroutes alors qu'on
sait que les autoroutes sont très peu
accidentogène bon est-ce que les routes
secondaires si les routes secondaires le
son je sais mais il ya un moment enfin
moi je sais ma c'est mon comportement
des conducteurs c'est qu'il ya un moment
quand on finit par ne plus aller vite on
va vite à une vitesse suffisante au fini
par le plu est attentif du tout enfin
c'est peut-être je trouve qu'il ya si je
trouve qu à un moment quand on roule
très lentement quand on se retrouve à
des arts ou non non je dis qu à un
moment où il ya un risque d' attention
quand on finit par être sûr qu'il est
clean canton filière être sûr des
vitesses 80 ça veut dire qu'on va rouler
entre 70 et 75
je vous propose néanmoins ouais je vous
propose néanmoins hervé morin d'écouté
chantal perrichon c'est la présidente de
la ligue contre la violence routière
elle vous interpelle sur cependant les
copains monsieur morin vous vous opposez
à une mesure qui pourrait sauver des
centaines de vies
cette mesure a été priorisé par les
experts du conseil national de sécurité
routière depuis plusieurs années elle a
été mise de côté car le gouvernement
précédent n'avez pas de courage
le premier ministre a du cran ils
s'intéressent enfin ce qui se passe dans
les départements dans les régions est-ce
que vous acceptez monsieur morin qu'un
père ou une mère qui accompagne son
enfant voiture puisse mourir sur le
chemin de l'école est-ce que vous
acceptez que des apprentis qui vont leur
centre d'apprentissage meur sur leur
chemin parce qu'il voulait étudier ces
voix là personne n'accepte moi je suis
père de quatre enfants
mon angoisse de tous les samedis soirs
c'est quand mon fils ou ma fille rentre
le soir justement alors attendez là je
termine et donc là qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour la lutte contre l'alcool contre
l'alcoolémie au volant
il ya une fois vous êtes contrôlés dans
votre vie de conducteurs combien de fois
vous l'avez été quasiment jamais or on
sait que la cdc
ce sont des hécatombes tous les
week-ends le samedi soir qu'est ce qu'on
fait contre ça pour la lutte contre la
toxicomanie alain sur la route qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour améliorer faire en sorte
que les départements puissent avoir des
routes moins dangereuses
ça c'est des sujets majeurs
peut-être que celui ci en état mais moi
ce que je ne comprends pas c'est
pourquoi on a pas eu l'étude complète ce
que je sais c'est que bien entendu j'ai
été je sais ce que c'est quand on a tous
connu ces drames là dans notre
environnement donc c'est pas c'est pas
la question mais mais considérer que
c'est la seule priorité je considère
canal certainement des plus importantes
que ça qui est notamment de lutter
contre l'alcool et la toxicomanie
l'entend dire est que cette réforme est
la critique de l'opposition sur cette
réforme
comme quoi macron serait finalement le
pressent dans des villes contre contre
la france rurale est ce que c'est une
critique que vous reprenez votre compte
est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour dire
que le président est plus urbain que
rural pense qu'il a besoin d'apprendre
ce qu'est le monde rural ça c'est clair
mais mais pense qu'il a est ce que c'est
un bon nombre d'attaqués tout simplement
sur l'exécutif je ne pense que ce n'est
pas le sujet je pense que c'est pas le
sujet sur lequel on doit être à mon avis
en permanence ok on donne son opinion je
les propos de la présidente sont
parfaitement on voit là on les entend
tous parce qu'on est tous tellement
bouleversée à chaque fois qu'un jeune
meurt sur la route ou un moins jeune
mais au tiatia donner mais je dis qu'à
le vendre des sujets sur lesquels on ne
va pas et notamment je le répète la
question de l'alcool et de la
toxicomanie au volant sur sur ces sujets
justement qui concerne le monde rural
les députés aient l'air ont beaucoup
mener le front sur les écoles les écoles
qui vont fermer les classes qui vont
fermer en zone rurale ils disent
notamment que c'est l'hécatombe et senna
est ce que vous vous porter aussi ce
point là est ce que dans votre région
par exemple des classes rurales vont
fermer à cause de la réforme du
gouvernement
il y aura des classes qui ferment ça ne
fait absolument aucun doute la seule
chose ce qu'on avait je crois entendu un
gouvernement expliqué qui aurait pas de
fermeture de classe
c'est bien ça m'apparaît parce que les
années précédentes
donc en clair il y aura forcément des
fermetures oui et alors tant pis si je
ne suis pas en accord avec mes camarades
de l'opposition mais il ya des
fermetures de classes qui s'imposent
déclaré démagogique des classes uniques
des classes uniques dont on sait que les
résultats scolaires sont moins bon est
ce qu'il faut absolument s'acharner à
les maintenir et donc il ya il faut
accepter aussi des mouvements de
population j'ai été maire d'une commune
dans laquelle j'ai accepté parfois
qu'une année en effet j'avais un déclin
démographique sur un an j'acceptais de
fermetures de classes
ce qu'il faut c'est que lorsque les cas
se remplissent en revanche on puisse au
24 voilà alors ap on peut faire de la
politique avec sa très démagogiques
jeudi qu' il ya d'autres combats que
cela a mené sur celui de la carte
judiciaire justement est ce que ce sont
ces mêmes mouvements de population que
vous évoquiez qu'il faut considérer pour
réformer la carte judiciaire vous l ua
garde des sceaux récemment ou est ce que
vous dites il faut garder tous ses
traits d'une eau la carte écoutez je
compte le gouvernement l'a entendu
puisque le gouvernement a décidé de
maintenir les cours d'appel de deux
conduits par cette promesse du
gouvernement l'été j'ai aussi tout j'ai
lu dans votre région enfin chez j'ai cru
comprendre qu'on en demande il n'y
aurait pas d'hécatombe en fait le même
effet toujours un moment mais ce que je
crois c'est que on a vécu une réforme
qui s'appelait la réforme dati de l'esab
2008 laissé des traces importantes et
qui doit au moins
enfin en clair il a été démontré que
fermer un tribunal pour 30 euros et
investir dans l'agrandissement d'un
autre tribunal pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse accueillir et faire justice
l'amortissement est entre 20 et 25 ans
est ce que vous connaissez vous des
investissements qui ont d autre des
temps d'amortissement aussi long non
donc ça prouve bien que ce n'est pas une
priorité absolue quand suite après ce
soit que que ça provoque d'aider des
complications dans la gestion du corps
des magistrats
je veux bien la multiplication des
points et peu de magistrats quand il ya
des absences etc
mais quand on voit le retour sur
investissement aussi faible
je crois qu'il ya pas pire message que
d'enlever encore
un service public d'une fonction
régalienne de l'état quand grosso modo
tout ou presque est déjà parti
concernant la réforme de l'apprentissage
vous condamnez vous la réforme telle
qu'elle a été arrêtée par le
gouvernement elle satisfait pourtant les
syndicats le medef vous vous dénoncez
une privatisation chandelle est-ce que
là aussi vous craignez une hécatombe
attendait la conter ses bras ou là là
moi j'ai la lecture elle est assez
simple l'apprentissage a souvent été
l'otage de la formation professionnelle
en clair il ya eu des jeux à deux bandes
à trois bandes où grosso modo on a
utilisé l'apprentissage en disant qu' on
est avec vous on est contre vous mâche
et c'est parce que derrière il y avait
la réforme d'apprendre formation
professionnelle qui pour les syndicats
et est une est un sujet extrêmement
important bien
à partir de là moi j'ai toujours pas
compris comment on va maintenir des
centres de formation pour apprentis avec
un prix national faut que un coup
nationale fonction tout faux deux mots
d'explication
en clair désormais ce ne sont plus les
régions qui ont des cartes de formation
qui elle discute avec chaque branche
professionnelle en disant voilà il ya
des demandes ya des entreprises on ou
des apprentis ono au niveau des centres
de formation pour apprentis à tel ou tel
endroit en fonction des besoins des
bassins d'emploi et de la jeunesse très
bien et on passe un système où vous
allez avoir un prix d'une formation
apprenti boulanger
admettons 5000 euros et un centre de
formation donc s'il a vingt apprentis
multiples ivan par 5000 et ça lui fait
son budget sauf qu'en vérité il n'ya pas
deux centres de formation qui margent la
même fac sont en vérité le prix il va
être fixée à partir d'un niveau moyen de
d'occupation c'est à dire qu'il va
falloir avoir 12 15 élèves pour que
grosso modo ce centre de formation
puisse vivre
or malheureusement il ya des tas de
centres de formation qui ne sont pas ces
niveaux là pourquoi parce qu'ils sont au
milieu rural parce qu'ils sont dans les
petites villes dans des lieux où la
démographie 17e mallardo qu'il va y
avoir une hécatombe les centres de
formation je prends un exemple simple
j'ai fait faire l'étude dans ma région
la normandie je sais que françois
bonneau a fait la même étude dans la
région centre
j'ai quarante et un centre qui cumule 29
millions d'euros de déficit qui qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire très
clairement que avec de tels niveaux
déficit c'est des centres de formation
dont une partie au moins des
apprentissages vont fermer et qui vont
disparaître en milieu rural bah oui
parce que vous avez des apps des centres
de formation c'est facile de mettre 40
élèves est ce que vous êtes dans une
grande agglomération et il ya des
centres de formation vous en avez 8 au
10 mai là où ils sont ils ne sont que 8
ou 10 c'est extrêmement utile et
nécessaire pour ce bassin pas parce que
derrière
si vous n'avez pas la main d'oeuvre et
puis les entreprises les entreprises
connaissent pas ce dernier sujet de
front dans ce moment avec l'exécutif
hervé morin morin le gouvernement
rendues publiques les modalités de
contrat financier entre les
collectivités territoriales et l'état
visiblement les régions de france que
vous présidez n'y trouve pas son compte
est ce que vous demandez aux régions de
boycotter ces négociations avec les
préfets coûté chacun est parti dans une
démarche simple en clair pour que nos
compatriotes comprennent l'essentiel de
la réduction de la dépense publique a
été effectué depuis plusieurs années par
les collectivités l'état n'a pas fait de
réduction c'est sur les collectivités
qu'on quasiment assumer la totalité de
la réduction des dépenses publiques
souvenez-vous des 50 milliards de
françois hollande cédé 53 de mémoire
vous dites dans l'aube avant tout a été
fait par les collectivités
là le gouvernement ne fait pas de
réduction de dépenses publiques et dit
encore aux collectivités cerveau de le
faire et en même temps nous explique
qu'on est stratégique sur toute une
série de sujets je prends des régions ce
que de formation professionnelle ou ce
que peu d'apprentissage le soutien sont
peu pressés nous les grands équipements
les infrastructures c'est nous les
grands mots les grands programmes de
recherche chez nous ben non à partir de
la relation avec l'état vous allez
négocier sur ces contrats ou moins
certains comme vous avez bertrand
valérie pécresse ont dit non et non
valérie a dit saviez a dit tout dépend
si l'état respecte ou non lui ses
engagements donc il ya j'ai une autre
discours on a une réunion des présidents
de régions de france mercredi
on évoquera donc cette question mercredi
entre nous moi je vais vous dire j'ai
pas de souci sur le rhin 2% sur moi que
ça dans mon budget donc
discussion valait une fine ce genre
domine mercredi mais il ya beaucoup de
collectifs beaucoup de régions contre
est sensiblement qui baisse leurs
dépenses de fonctionnement
donc en clair ce que je veux pas de jeu
pas les négocier que la préfète je
donnerai mon budget j'irai voilà je suis
à moins de 1 2 ou quoi c'est plus les
pieds allez on aborde la dernière partie
de cette émission hervé morin on va
parler du centre et c'est pas le bria
qui vous pose cette première question
sur le centre combien de divisions
mais oui parce qu'on a lui dit on a le
modem garde bic en marche
évidemment parti radical le mouvement
radical par le kiki égard la conséquence
de la réunification du parti radical de
gauche et du parti radical valoisien
puis à vous bon bref combien de
divisions
il n'y a t'il pas de doute un trouble
quant au centre ont coûté moins pour
l'instant ce qui compte
je suis pas demain soir nous lançons
nous manque est une association qui
s'appelle les territoires territoire en
clair pour moi la question c'est le
renouvellement de du projet politique
sortir des systèmes pavlovien dans
lesquelles nous sommes où nous évoquons
toujours les sujets de la même façon
avec les mêmes réflexes
je pense que ce qu'il faut c'est faire
revenir un certain nombre de nos
compatriotes dans les sujets de fond en
ayant une démarche participative c'est
elle que je lance il s'agit pas d'un
parti politique s'agit simplement d'une
association non mais vous vous
différencier par exemple de jean
christophe lagarde qui vient d'être
décidé
écoutez moi je pense que je suis
profondément girondins voilà pense que
je suis libéral
voilà il ya des sujets sur lesquels on a
des différences de perceptions je veux
pas faire le point ça et c'est pas mon
débat mon débat pour le moment c'est de
faire en sorte que nous soyons en mesure
de dire à des élus locaux de dire à des
compatriotes et à des citoyens qui sont
issus globalement notre mouvance
politique de droite et du centre les
réunions que j'effectue en province sont
des réunions où viennent des
sympathisants et l'ère des dvd etc
c'est pas d union centriste sont des
réunions où je dis aux gens est-ce qu'on
peut essayer d'aborder autrement sont
deux sujets est ce qu'on peut essayer de
réfléchir ensemble et que vous
participiez à l'élaboration un
renouvellement d'un projet politique et
l'idée c'est qu'en début juillet à nîmes
nous nous retrouvions tous ensemble pour
en effet couché sur le papier un certain
nombre de propositions sur le sujet je
prends un exemple simple vous connaissez
probablement ce grand sociologue jean
viard qui a expliqué que démontrer qu'on
vivait désormais plus longtemps et donc
on avait un capital temps considérable
on travaille moins longtemps qu'au début
du 20e siècle travaille deux fois moins
longtemps on dort moins et on vit plus
longtemps donc on a un espace temps
considérable at on bâtit une société une
organisation de la société à partir du
fait qu' on a des centaines de milliers
d'heures désormais disponible est ce que
on a construit un modèle
intergénérationnel de solidarité puisque
aujourd'hui par exemple la plupart du
temps vous mériterez qu'à 60 ans ou plus
tard et que on peut peut-être pensé à un
système dans lequel on a des mécanismes
solidarité entre les générations
est-ce qu'on a bâti un modèle de société
dans lequel on fait appel à cet immense
générosité liés à des compatriotes qui
désormais au moment où arrive leur
retraite
on attend disponibles considérables ils
le font déjà naturellement mais il ya
des organisations sociales a pensé et
bien parce qu'on a plus à travailler sur
des sujets de fond quelle est la place
du digital de l'intelligence
artificielle dont vous allez le faire
avec qui avec qui vous souhaitez le
faire et bien nous le faisons à travers
d'abord un système participatif est par
ailleurs avec un centre de
le mans terre des mulets faire venir
vers vous dlr qui sont un peu déçus de
la ligne laurent wauquiez par exemple on
a on a voilà moi je prends un exemple
simple on le fait avec le maire de la
ville qui peut être et l'eire qui peut
être divers droite peu importe qui
invite des élus des citoyens des
responsables d'associations l'idée c'est
pas le politique assène un discours ces
politiques ou des peas et qui ensuite
participé à un échange pour qu'on essaie
de renouveler un peu cette pensée
politique mais est ce que cette démarche
elle n'a pas déjà été accompli par
emmanuel maman est ce qui n'a pas déjà
siphonner et donc et vous voyez
vous-même 4 avait un sombre de questions
vous avez déjà ouvert des pistes quand
on évoque la question de l'apprentissage
quand on évoque la question de la
formation professionnelle quand on
évoque le sentiment d'abandon du monde
rural
là aussi des sujets sur lesquels d'ores
et déjà on peut estimer que même si
emmanuel macron avait eu cette démarche
là cette démarche là a encore des
raisons d'être
en tout cas jean christophe lagarde il
semblait soulagé un samedi d'être réélu
à la tête de l'ue délit avec la
bénédiction de jean louis borloo qui
était venu y faire un tour je vous
propose de l'écouter chien la nouvelle
étape de vie de l'udps et y est c'est le
plus grand merci que je vous le dis ce
que je veux vous formulez c'est
jean-louis temps sur rennes est surpris
étonné mais en tout cas je suis sûr ravi
une famille désormais unifié et pacifié
et libéré et ça va changer notre façon
de faire de la politique unifiée c'est
une nouveauté
hervé nous faisait rire tout à l'heure
mais je n'ai pas son talent n'empêche
que c'est bien la première fois que je
monte à une tribune sans me demander
quel est le couteau qui est dans mon dos
voilà un parti unifié apaisé je vous
sentez visé quand tu parles de couteau
dans le dos je prends 4 à karbala je
pense que
on n'a pas la même conception de la
politique ça me va très bien comme ça à
vrai dire pas que les liens qui fait de
l'humour à votre égard
il ya aussi arts de marseille qui
apparaît david perdu de vue etc
il a ironisé sur les défections ces
derniers mois donc en vous renvoie
citant notamment notamment au centre
comment pouvez-vous faire pour être à
nouveau audible finalement ils s'en vont
expliqué adib où ils ont ils ont un
groupe parlementaire
mais le groupe parlementaire et des
composés de ford de parlementaires qui
sont notamment issus de l'information
politique celle du parti radical issus
de différentes formations qui sont pas
forcément l'idée y commencer ça la
question n'est pas là gr après si vous
avez eu le sentiment que liddy avait été
audibles de l'action présidentielle
faite moi signe si vous avez le
sentiment que j ai été audi dans tous
les grands débats politiques de ces
derniers années
faites moi si donc moi j'ai le sentiment
que il ya une autre démarche à bâtir que
celle de rester dans un dans 1 dans un
jeu pas employer le mot dur dans une
famille politique dans un parti
politique insiste m voilà je pense qu'il
ya autre une autre façon d'aborder les
choses c'est pas par hasard d'ailleurs
que les quatre présidents de régions que
sont christian estrosi valérie pécresse
avis bertrand et votre serviteur ont
tous entrepris une démarche radicalement
différente
regardez on n'est pas en train de se
demander comme le fait jean christophe
lagarde ou d'autres est-ce que j'ai
participé à la majorité pas participé à
la majorité
m taper sur vos pieds tout en restant
avec laurent wauquiez dans la même
majorité en région rhône alpes auvergne
rhône-alpes
bon bref moi c'est pas mais des balles
c'est pas mon sujet ça un bon sujet
c'est plutôt qu'on essaie de bâtir un
nouveau projet et qu'on essaie d'aborder
des sujets sur lesquels on voit bien
qu'il ya des transformations majeures
pour le pays ensuite que le le monde
politique soit absent des débats sur le
digital l'intelligence artificielle sur
comment construire une démocratie
nouvelle dès lors que on voit bien qu
internet un jour ou l'autre quoi le
digital va finir par impacter la
démocratie représentative 5 semble des
sujets qu'on a le droit de regarder on
est loin des élections est donc en droit
de prendre de la hauteur
charlotte en parlant des élections il y
en a quand même
une avenir c'est l'élection des
européennes qui va être très importante
pour tous dans cette recomposition
politique actuelle alors lui des idées
et de le redire encore une fois mais a
décidé de ne plus faire d'alliance avec
l air vous vous ambitionnez de fait de
ne pas faire d'alliance non plus de
présenter de votre propre liste de faire
des alliances avec qui comment comme si
vous pensez que lesdits frais combien
aux élections ajoute l âme d'accord mais
regardez regardez les dernières et
quelques sondages qui sont pas parus
c'est assez symbolique du score qui est
fait je crois un seul 3 3%
mais qu'est ce que vous vous en les
dogues aventures de cette grande rice
d'euros piste avec la république en
marche avec remo des navettes caucase et
cherokee dit est ce que vous pourriez
intégrer une telle liste pour les urnes
- je ne suis pas sur ce schéma pour le
moment le schéma pour moi c'est un de
faire en sorte que ma région réussissent
comme elle est en train de réussir sur
l'économie en ayant des chiffres
meilleurs que la moyenne nationale c'est
de faire en sorte que en effet avec le
gouvernement tong présent des régions de
france il y ait de bonnes réformes sur
des sujets absolument systémique et
fondamentaux comme la formation
professionnelle ça c'est pour moi les
priorités la question des européennes
pardon de le dire elle n'intéresse
personne
sinon vous et quelques politiques non
mais pour le moment c'est pas si
longtemps ça au nom et quelques jours
vous pensez que c'est on a besoin de son
d'en parler d'eux dès maintenant
pourquoi pas c'est pourtant un sujet
important emmanuel macron mais l'europe
au centre d'un certain nombre on verra
bien si ces réformes sont faites mais
pop et il peut pas les faire ça le bien
entendu et pour l'instant on n'a pas
beaucoup d'échos sur le grand discours
que fut le sien et que j'ai aimé quel
était son discours à athènes
dernière question par les autres est si
long plus proche de nous ce sont les
parties elles avaient jusqu'à tiff par
celle qu'on a notamment eu lieu ce week
end on voir un redressement des
républicains voire du ps en haute
garonne et puis parallèlement un
affaiblissement de la république en
marche ça vous semble trop bon cv
justice partiale ça veut dire quelque
chose de louche ce camion c'est déjà la
fin de du nouveau maire devant servir je
vais dire quel que soit le taux de
participation ça veut dire quelque chose
que je veux dire bon voilà je pense
qu'une partie de nos compatriotes
clairement
aussi a envie d'adresser un message à la
majorité que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
on va pas revenir sur ces thèmes je
crois très clairement qu'on ne peut pas
simplement traiter par le mépris parce
qu'ils auraient une participation faible
le résultat de ces différences de ces
différents scrutins
et donc ces scrutins ont eu lieu s'il
avait été bon pour la majorité la
majorité n'aurait pas manqué de le faire
savoir
ils ne sont pas bons parce que très
clairement partie de nos compatriotes
ils sont vendus là non oui mais vous
savez bien que les élections outre-mer
parfois répondre à des équations qui
sont des équations plus complet plus
particulière donc la recomposition du la
recomposition du paysage politique la
politique n'est absolument pas terminée
oui et on a encore devant nous au moins
deux bonnes années pour voir les choses
se reconfigurer ok merci beaucoup et
hervé morin d'avoir essayé notre invité
ce soir merci paul merci charlotte est
très bonne soirée à tous sur l'antenne
de public sénat
[Musique]